a new field thus opens up for
observation in the behavior of
consciousness in its actuality
psychology contains the collection of
laws in accordance with which spirit
relates itself in various ways to the
various modes of its actuality as an
other pneus already given on the one
hand spirit receives these modes into
itself conforming to the habits customs
and way of thinking all ready to hand as
being that in which it is an actuality
or as an object to itself and on the
other hand spirit knows itself is
spontaneously active in face of them and
in singling out from them something for
itself it follows its own inclinations
and desires making the object conform to
it in the first case it behaves
negatively towards itself as an
individuality in the second case
negatively towards itself as a universal
being according to the first aspect
independence gives to what is already
there merely the form of self conscious
individuality as such and as regards the
content remains within the general
actuality already given according to the
second aspect it gives the actuality at
least a peculiar modification which does
not contradict its essential content or
one even where by the individual qua
particular actuality with a peculiar
content sets itself in opposition to the
general actuality and opposition which
becomes wrongdoing or crime when it sets
aside that actuality in a merely
individual manner or when it does this
in a general way and thus for all
putting another world another right law
and customs in place of those already
existing
here in paragraph 302 Hagel is now
telling us about a shift to observation
of behavior of consciousness in its
actuality a shift in observation which
is self-observation also observation of
other people of course and then trying
to correlate one's own behavior to those
of others that have been observed and
we're talking about our conscious beings
in their actuality no longer in the
abstract but in how they are how they
present themselves within the world
within within the matrix of society and
we're observing behavior we're observing
how people actually behave how they act
what they do we're trying to think about
motives we're trying to think about what
we can predict and Hagel is laying out
this duality now between what we could
call the the laws or the norms of some
sort of observational psychology
observational psychology not in the
sense that we give it today where we
have departments of that and it's a very
you know you know demarcate discipline
separate from everything else but it's
part of philosophy essentially and then
the individual so this would include not
only psychology but also what we call
political science economics anything
that he has to do with human behavior
ethics would also fit in here and I
think that in this this passage in
particular you can see Hagel grappling
with but also trying to go beyond the
the heritage of can't and also konsa
mediate successors so Hagel tells us
that a new field opens up for
observation this is what that field is
focused on psychology says contains the
collection of laws in accordance with
which spirit relates itself in various
ways to the various modes of its
actuality as an other nuh Saul ready
given so what does that mean well think
about what Spirit has meant for Hegel as
the phenomenology of spirit right and
there's a section spirit further on
beyond reason we've already seen spirit
raise itself up as an issue as a you
might say a towel something that we're
aiming at both in the preface and also
in the self-consciousness section
there's been a lot of interesting
discussions sort of hinting at what
what's going on and we're talking about
a community so reason has been this
section in which we have the observing
consciousness you know looking at things
and also realizing that it is finding
itself out there in the world of which
it is it is reason right the world for
which reason exists spirit now is going
to have to do with the relationship of a
consciousness with another consciousness
but also with other conscious mrs. and
this is one way in which it's it's
making sense of that an early wed so
Hagel goes on and he says psychology is
is providing us with one side of this so
he says on the one hand spirit receives
these modes into itself conforming to
the habits and customs way of thinking
already at hand as being that in which
it is an actuality or an object to
itself what are we talking about here
what is the spirit the individual the
the person is internalizing is making
part of themselves this larger social
matrix of meaning meaning not just in
the sense of well this is a book but in
the sense of this is a book and this
should be acted upon in this particular
way and that's a good thing or a bad
thing all this this a firm tissue we
might say what's going to later be
called substantial life or the the
ethical that's going to come up in the
later in the reason section and also
very much in the spirit section so the
individual conforms to these habits
customs ways of thinking
in broader sense laws overarching norms
so you know being an Athenian for
example in ancient Athens after the
democracy is established doesn't
preclude being an oligarch but it means
thinking that you have the right to
present oligarchy as a viable option
within the democracy that has been
established right if you're in Sparta
well you're doing with a whole different
set of laws governing that particular
framework governing that particular
system so on the one side we have the
individual as treating themselves as an
object making themselves understandable
to themselves in terms of this matrix of
norms on the other side we have
something quite interesting this is
where we have a dualism he says here we
go on the other hand spirit knows itself
as spontaneously active in the face of
them and in singling them out as
something for itself it follows its own
inclinations and desires making the
object conform to it what is the object
well we'll think about that in just a
moment but notice what he says this that
the individual who is spirit in this
case spontaneously active in the face of
these laws they're not just blind
necessity that imposes itself upon a
person at a certain level the person
makes a choice or a series of choices to
take on these laws it goes beyond just
that though it's not just an off on
singling out something for itself what
we're talking about here is what we
could we could say is interpretive
adaptation these laws the whole you know
fabric of ethical life as Hagel's later
going to call it we pick out what
elements we pick out what parts of it we
want to appropriate for ourselves and
underst
enter cells within so for example
professional life right I'm a doctor
that means that the things that apply to
lawyers probably don't apply to me but
our social expectations of doctors and
medicine in general I take that on but
then I decide how i'm going to adapt
that in my present circumstances and
hegel talks here about following one's
own inclinations and desires and that's
language almost straight out of Conte
right we can say that this is what we
have here are not heteronomous ohne me
but rather to different kinds of header
on amiright the header on Amir the
individual following their inclinations
and desires and that of these in certain
respects arbitrarily given but then
presented as necessary social
constraints social norms ways of
understanding things that provide an
interest subjectivity and Hagel thinks
this is all going on within every single
individual within the social fabric and
that is part of what is going on in the
development of spirit of course the
individuals probably not all that
conscious of that but that is what is
happening so he goes on and he says here
we go in the first case over here spirit
behaves negatively towards itself as an
individuality why because it subverts or
subordinates its individuality and it as
an individual it reduces its
individuality so it can fit in to the
norms here in the second case negatively
towards itself as a universal being the
universal being is yielded by this over
here I am an Athenian I am a doctor I am
a 21st century middle aged man right all
those sorts of things we're treating the
universal is something that we in
certain respects can depart from and
dispensed with now angle so some really
interesting things about this so he says
according to the first aspect
independence gives what is already there
merely the form of self conscious
individuality as such right here's the
norms you are self-conscious about it
conform
to the norms right and then he says as
regards the content remains within the
general actuality already given this is
an actuality despite the fact that you
know in a certain respect social norms
exist everywhere and nowhere they are in
actuality you don't find a person who
doesn't have some internalized social
norms so we go on and he says according
to the second aspect it gives the
actuality a peculiar specific its own
personal modification which does not
contradict it's essential content or one
even where by the individual qua
particular actuality with a peculiar
content sets itself in opposition to the
general actuality so it could be sort of
a hey we've got these norms in place and
I'm just going to find my place within
them and I'm happy because I adapt them
to myself and I follow my inclinations
and desires and everything's going great
or there can be a conflict where the
person is like this is I'm not living
with this sort of life you're and I
could tell me what to do we actually
have like a you know in our society and
within our you know this shows you that
there's some self referential T involved
in these norms we have a special time
picked out for that right adolescence
screw you man you're not going to tell
me what to do and how to live and that's
that's that's not actually how most
adolescents behave but there's some
element of that and then many of them
continue that into adulthood but that's
part of why as part of how the social
conflict between the society and with
its norms and the individual adapting
things can take place he goes on a
little bit further and he says there's
two ways this opposition can happen one
of them is wrongdoing or crime and this
is this is what happens when the
individual is in conflict with the
overarching societal norms and they're
in conflict with it merely as an
individual I'm not going to respect
property
I am going to walk across this guy's
lawn whether he likes it or not whether
the laws of the city tell me that I'm
allowed to or not I'm going to follow my
inclinations and desires and then you
get arrested for trespassing right
that's a crime I'm not going to respect
property I'm not going to respect sexual
integrity i'm not going to respect life
you know as an individual that that
means it's crime Hagel says something
else that is quite important here though
as well something with you might say
revolutionary implications he says when
it does is in a general way thus for all
putting another world another right law
and customs in place of those already
existing then what we have is no longer
just a clash between the universal and
the individual but between the old
universal and the new more Universal
universal and this is part of what
happens through the progress in in world
history that's where we see spirit in
its development taking place and we're
going to see a lot of dynamics like that
we've already seen some like that before
with the skepticism stoicism skepticism
and the unhappy consciousness sections
but those were not really fully
developed in in that way when they
become social movements like that of the
Enlightenment that's when we have what
Hagel is talking about here
observational psychology which in the
first instance records its perceptions
of the general modes coming to its
notice in the act of consciousness comes
across all sorts of faculties
inclinations and passions and since
while recounting the details of this
collection it cannot help recalling the
unity of self-consciousness it must at
least go so far as to be astonished that
such a contingent medley of
heterogeneous beings can be together in
the mind like things in a bag or more
especially since they show themselves to
be not dead and earth things but
Restless movements
here in paragraph 303 very short
paragraph Hagel is just pointing out to
us essentially one main issue and that
has to do with the way observational
psychology finds itself working remember
that we are the sort of riders along
watching consciousness make sense of its
own attempts to come to terms with the
totality of what it is studying and to
find its truth so this is a case where
observational psychology as a way in
which consciousness is is grappling with
this this project is finding out that it
doesn't really have the truth or at
least that there's a conflict here so he
says that observational psychology and
we ought to understand it not just as a
discipline but primarily as an activity
that that discipline would then somehow
represent the results of a way of you
know furthering right a way of adding to
the stock of common ideas for humankind
so the observational psychology in the
first place records its perceptions of
the general modes coming to its notice
in the act of consciousness and this is
what we're trying to understand in terms
of laws of consciousness laws of thought
right so how does that really play
itself out when we get to something
that's more concrete here Hagel talks
about a whole mess a whole swarm of
heterogeneous faculties inclinations
passions we've already had some previous
exposure to this in thinking about as
we're talking in the previous section
sensibility irritability reproduction
now we're actually thinking in terms of
faculties of the human being and their
capacity for thinking or feeling or for
acting we also had some discussion of
this back in the self-consciousness
section with the unhappy consciousness
and the fact that these faculties were
given to it by
it's other which was the divine but
we're putting that aside for the moment
now we're trying to study these through
observing other people and through
observing ourselves now what's the
problem here Hagel says that this is a
contingent medley of heterogeneous
beings what does that mean well you know
think about is a great you know term
medley and you know it's got some
connotations in English that I think are
actually quite helpful here that aren't
there in the original German but when
you I don't like medleys I don't like to
hear them because for me you know we
move from one song a bit of one song to
another song to another song you never
hear a whole song instead you're hearing
like the most popular 12 bars from that
song I actually hate listening to that
sort of stuff in part because I like
things to cohere if I wanted to jump
from thing to thing to thing sort of
like having a you know a taste where
they've piled in you know every single
taste flavor possible and it changes and
then you're like I've had enough of that
give me something that I can sink my
teeth into and so that is what Hagel is
talking about here we've got this mess
of stuff that psychology is observing
and remember we're not just talking
about psychology we're talking about
economics political science you know
moral philosophy this this whole thing
that has to do with the human being in
action what's the problem here Hagel
says that this in some respects
contradicts something that we know about
the human being that is the unity of
self-consciousness he says while
recounting the details of this
collection it cannot help what is it
observational psychology cannot help
recalling the unity of
self-consciousness it must be astonished
that these sort of things can all be in
the mind like a like you know objects in
a bag because the fact that
self-consciousness is a Unity means that
these somehow you need to be unified
into a coherent system and even more so
he says since these things are not
themselves dead in earth things
but restless movements so the challenge
here is to understand how all of this
stuff actually fits together
observation and recounting these various
faculties is keeping to the universal
aspect the unity of these manifold
capacities is the opposite aspect to
this universality the actual
individuality however to take up again
in this way the distinctive actual
individuality is and to recount that one
man has more inclination for this
another for that that one has more
intelligence than another all this is
much less interesting even than
enumerated species of insects mosses and
so forth for these give observation the
right to take them thus think singly and
uncompromising particular ization on the
other hand to take contingent conscious
individuality unintelligent ly as a
manifestation that is single and
separate involves a contradiction since
its essential nature is the universal of
spirit but since observation and
apprehending it and douse it with the
form of universality it finds its law
and seems now to have a rational aim and
to be engaged in a necessary activity
paragraph 304 is picking up from this
this contingent medley is you know this
whole bag of tricks you might say
faculties inclinations passions the
things that we can use observational
psychology to say something about on the
whole you know about human beings you
know when we come up with
generalizations like for example you
know one of the contemporary internet
ones is similar to Gresham's laws far as
currency that bad currency drives out
good I forget exactly what the one is
for the internet that says that bad data
tends to swamp good data as opposed to
what we would normally think those are
things about human behavior right and so
we can we can come up with certain laws
or rules or norms that function both in
a descriptive and also a prescriptive
way and that's on the side of the
universal and on the other side we have
individuality and we talked about the
problem that the unity of
self-consciousness doesn't seem to quite
fit with the fact that we have this
whole you know grab bag over here of
stuff that the psychologists are
focusing on how is it that the human
being is in fact a coherent dynamic
whole when the the perspective that the
psychologists are affording us is this
you know sort of partitioned off
compartmentalized ba so Hagel says here
that observation and recounting these
faculties is keeping to the universal
aspect and the opposite to this is the
unity of the manifold capacities the
actual individuality now notice what
he's going to do here he says but
individuality isn't individuality all by
itself individuality is individuality in
the plural you don't just have one
individual you couldn't talk about the
social if all you had was one being
right so he says to take up again in
this way the distinctive actual
individuality Zen to recount that one
man has more inclination
for this another for that so what we're
doing is we're looking at the
individuals and now say we're measuring
them with the metrics that have been
yielded by study of this particular
faculty or this particular inclination
or as our psychologist like to say today
these correlations of dependent and
independent variables right and we look
at individuals in the light of that
perhaps giving them inventories having
them take a survey right how many what's
the balance of positive to negative
emotions in your life why don't you
track that over time well Jimmy finds
out one thing and Susie finds out
another thing and Robert finds out
another thing and Hagel says who cares
that's not interesting at all now that's
a interesting thing by itself to say
isn't it does that mean Hagel's just
sort of a the the equivalent of a
psychological Philistine saying Oh
psychology psychology not interested in
that no she says all this is much less
interesting even than enumerated species
of insects or molasses for these give
observation the right to take them
singly and on comprehending Lee because
they belong essentially to the element
of contingent particular ization when
we're looking at species that there's a
certain purpose to doing things that way
but he says on the other hand to take
conscious individuality unintelligent
Lee as a manifestation that single and
separate involves a contradiction why
it's essential nature is the universal
of spirit what does that mean this
individuality this individuality this
individuality all of them are in fact
spirit just as much as the other we
don't have any any one individual who is
more of an individual than the others at
least that at this point in time so he
says observation in apprehending it and
douse it with the form of universality
that's over here and it's producing some
sort of law
right it seems now to have a rational
aim and to be engaged in a necessary
activity what is engaged in a necessary
activity observation observation of
individuality so is this going to hold
and the question we've been looking for
law all this time great what is that law
going to be
the moments constituting the content of
the law are on the one hand the
individuality itself on the other hand
it's Universal inorganic nature that is
the given circumstances situation habits
customs religion and so on from these
the specific individuality is to be
comprehended they embrace specific as
well as universal elements and are at
the same time something given something
which provides material for observation
and which on the other hand expresses
itself in the form of individuality
paragraph 305 is very short and there's
really only one main thing being
developed there but there's some
interesting implications that I want to
call your attention to so let's look
first at what Hales actually saying so
he talks it now about the law right and
we weren't able to have a law for
organic being but now we want to have a
law for observing consciousness and he
says that the moments constituting the
the content of the law are on the one
hand the individuality on the other hand
the universal inorganic nature what is
it in organic nature while he tells us
that it's these Givens right
circumstances the situation habits
custom knows you talked about religion
to this is a time when people are more
religious but it's still a major force
in our own time and we often think that
if we know something about you know
these this background material or you
know where somebody was raised or or you
know what sort of ideological things are
floating around in their environment
that we know a lot about them that we
can generalize and say that the specific
individuality can be comprehended in
terms of these things right oh you're a
Catholic well then you must think this
way I mean nobody who actually spends
any time within the Catholic Church
thinks that to be the case because you
is very quickly encounter a diversity of
opinion and perspective and it's that
way with many other religions as
churches and religions as well we can
also say this about political standpoint
so we can say this about being educated
oh you went to an Ivy League school you
must be an elitist well no I mean at the
Ivy League's they they often teach this
sort of a galit Arianism that doesn't
often trickle down into actual gallant
Arianism but that's that's the the
makeup but what's to say that that that
person who went to that place isn't
going to be the exception to the norm
that's not being considered here what's
what's going on is we're saying yeah as
observational psychologist we can
look at this stuff over here and then we
can make sense out of the individuality
because the individuality is really an
expression of all of this stuff over
here now what are the implications of
this where have we seen this discussion
of one thing one moment of a law being
the expression of another that's the
seemed to bring back to mind the outer
is the expression of the inner that
we've heard so much in the past right
now it's no longer outer and inner as a
matter of fact this is more the inner in
certain respects because it's got
interior T and this is the outer this is
what we can observe but it's still about
expression it's still about a sort of
reductionism about saying well because
we understand this and we don't really
even understand this but we pretend like
we do we now know everything about the
individual is that really the case we're
going to see that this is is a
interesting line and think about how
prevalent this is in our own time people
making all sorts of predictions people
making all sorts of accusations about
who and what another person is and what
sort of standpoint they must have and
whether they can understand certain
experiences or even say certain words
and we can go on and on a lot of that is
based on this notion of what we could
call social determinism you know
something about the social matrix you
know the individual Hagel is going to
combat that one of the other key
implications of this is when you hear
people saying oh Hagel thinks that
history is just this massive determinism
and nobody can do other wise than
they're doing everybody's just sort of
stuck and there's no real freedom this
is one of those paragraphs where human
freedom is coming to the fore as
something that you know it is not going
to allow itself to be reduced merely to
social facts
you